bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi ogni si è
mosso tutto si è bloccato fra miss e
mister ha bloccato il gioco di brutto ma
ci siamo a riportare quello e quindi
ragazzi siamo tassiamo sia perché dove
dove cazzo siamo siamo davanti a una
casa bellissima non si sa come ci siamo
arrivati in macchina e quindi ragazzi
visto che la macchina funzionava così
bene perché non ci fermiamo davanti a
questa casa abbandonata bellissima
immersa nel verde buongiorno datato va a
fuoco qualcosa di perfetto già non siamo
neanche entrati java fuoco qualcosa ha
permesso buongiorno sentite sono sono il
nuovo vicino già un buon consiglio
capite di rifare il giardino che
veramente non lo so messo non benissimo
buongiorno c'è qualcuno c'è nessuno
ragazzi io mi intrufolo nelle case degli
altri senza un [ __ ] motivo è scazzo
le sedie c'è [ __ ] tornati ragazzi
quello che andava fuoco da camino quindi
va benissimo così io sono al piano di
sopra e c'è mica nessuno o che belletto
facciamoci una riposata perché
giustamente con la macchina accesa fuori
ma andiamo nei letti degli altri perché
non c'è nessuno che cazzo giocato a fare
sta roba non c'è nessuno o buongiorno
che cazzo è successo di preciso sì ma
state calmi io qua su tranqui ok
perfetto se anche adulti che credo
proprio che non ci arriverò mai più
copie affetto ragazzi vi annuncio con
gioia che siamo intrappolati nelle
fondamenta di questa casa perfetto
avevamo la macchina che funzionava ma no
ma chi cazzo è frega andiamo nelle
fondamenta delle case così dove che
cos'è sta roba
sentite mio consiglio non solo avete mai
sentito parlare di rubinetti
no perché io qua e non è che poi si può
allargare pavimento ogni volta che si
tira lo sciacquone l'eccesso tratto
ragazzi stanno tirato lo sciacquone non
ritrovarci una merda prima di babe non
importa comunque nuova applicazione per
l'iphone ai torce 2.0 fantasia hi can
can del devo martellare le porte
perfetto dove siamo
praga è normale ci stiamo addentrando
sempre di più nel che cazzo successo va
beh io non so che cazzo succede uscita
uscita uscita di qua buongiorno senta e
già che c'è mi apre la porta visto che
ah ma allora proprio stronza e non ti
offendere ma sei proprio una [ __ ] di
quelle potenti e pedona luce vedo del
sangue ma avendo una luce quindi va bene
la macchina
no non può non ci posso credere non ci
posso credere non me ne frega un cazzo
della nota c'è la macchina c'era lo zio
oddio ho già in mente macchina dette
banchi entra villaggio ragazzi chi cazzo
è quello c'è un tizio c'è un tizio di
fuori che cammina a caso non si sente
facciamo cose facciamo finta di essere
in gta v foto la macchina e me ne vado
non sia che giochi a nascondino t'ho
visto guarda bene ok ok giochiamo
giochiamo la sua dirlo quanto ai
giochiamo a nascondino quanto volte ok
non ti non ti ho visto in realtà non ti
ho visto sei nascosto bellissimo invece
[Musica]
e basta ragazzi perché se non fessi
purtroppo mai non vorrei mai che inizia
a sabha la re non vorrei vederlo così
cos'è sta roba un fumo senti è
scoraggiato cosa dove cazzo no no no no
che c'era la ma c'era la macchina c'era
la [ __ ] macchina poteva potevo uscire
da sta merda perché perché sono entrato
nella scoreggia ma [ __ ] macchia
non la prendo la [ __ ] chiave non l'ho
presa dove non importa allora senti
zione su tutt correggi subito
ok ok va berlusconi giorno va bene che
vuoi fai quello che vuoi
fai quello che vuoi non mi sta più
seguendo fortunatamente ragazzi ho
trovato lakhtin credo sia la chiave
dell'uscita si ragazzi sono uscito sono
uscito of soul uscito a marra siete
bastardi
ferma ferma minima allora mi dispiace di
averti chiamato [ __ ] prima non era
mia intenzione ma allora sei proprio
[ __ ] ma forte posizionamento non ho
capito ma non me ne frega un cazzo
andiamo avanti perché sono finiamo cos'è
sta roba
siamo ok adesso sono fuori [ __ ] vi
faccio a piedi la tangenziale
mi son rotto i [ __ ] di andare in
giro me ne frega niente non me ne frega
solo perso la macchina base allora senti
devi stare ferma allora porca [ __ ]
non faccio il giro ti prendo a calci nel
culo dove sei
dove dovete via vieni qui dove vai
l'ho vista l'ho vista questa lo è ma
guarda se mi deve smettere di funzionare
la torcia adesso ma porca [ __ ] tra
l'altro se mi date un accendino ci pensò
il cos'è sta roba è apparsa adesso non
ho vista prima perfetto mica sbloccato
la porta no no ma sarebbe non ci posso
credere una cosa che faccio che funziona
uscita ha funzionato
no se bruciasse ha bruciato la lampadina
non avevo dubbi guarda lo sapevo
buongiorno sono fuori j vengo in pace
ok molti ragazzi troppo ragazzi ma sto
tizio costo collo che si ritrova può
fare attacchi terroristici con
terroristi
era pessima ma proprio pessima vabbè io
io io bado di là se non mi dispiace
benissimo sosta robot ragazzi non si
capisce una minchia in sto gioco ma
vendiamo avanza un portale quindi lo
piglia basta che usciamo da sta roba per
favore fatemi aprire le porte malizia un
perfetto questa va in via di qui che che
fai il bello che usciamo usciamo
tranquilli
madonna che grafica chat si si il mare
[ __ ] va dal nuoto ragazzi ci
vediamo alle hawaii mi trovate su
spiaggiato da qualche parte non so dove
ma va bene da qualsiasi cosa c'è un
portale laggiù credo che debba usare ma
sentite non possiamo andare tipo a nuoto
non lo so magari spuntiamo in calabria
non si sa ragazzi basta che abbiamo
visto non penso veramente
devo cambiare il fusibile così funziona
la porta d'uscita a perfetto se ce n'era
uno qui e devo ammettere a devo metterli
li mette in automatico perfetto ragazzi
devo trovare due fusibili veroli non
incontrare il mio amico dal collo lungo
perché non mi piace come ragazzo ve lo
dico già fatemi loggare su facebook
vedere le notifiche non va beh la
tastiera andato a [ __ ] quindi non lo
diamo su facebook è meglio comunque
sappiate che se lui si arriva il tizio
di prima ci faccio una foto all'otago
poi sono cazzi suoi e cioè new york al
sole da non rompermi le palle cos'è sta
roba da paranormal computer stima zio ma
venivi star calmo perché qua allora io
non ho insultato prima di tutto quindi o
ti dai una calmata
o ti presento il mio amico collo lungo
no perché non è non è tanto amiche
allora senti amico mio
c'è un computer che vuoi fare la tua
conoscenza io io te lo lascio qui in
paglia vedere maledizione che non ha
capito un cazzo della vita o il computer
cos'è questo premere ok ok ci siamo
siamo alla potuta uscita sono cazzi tuoi
io te l'ho detto è ok dove cazzolato non
mi fa non mi non mi fate si scherzi ai
ragazzi e poi è sparito il mio amico
male di ciò che è ok ok abiti ok
perfetto ragazzi adesso ci dovremmo
essere ma che non dovrebbe rompere i
[ __ ] perché non c'è più qui ok no
c'è di nuovo c'è di nuovo è ma sei
stronzo [ __ ] su cup su 99 di questo che
lo vede lo vede aiuto aiuto non corre
più non vuole più umano
allora tu dovessi essere figlio di
quella tizia di prima perché sei un
figlio di botte come allora fermo ok
vieni vieni sai dove ti infilo adesso la
testa lo sai nome ma è meglio che tu non
lo sappia maledizione vieni qui dove sei
vieni dove cazzo dov'è andato no perché
ok ok ok ci siamo all'inizio
un inizio sì sì sì ok ok ci sto facendo
già sto facendo uscita l'uscita ragazzi
ok non sono ok lì e lì
apriti bastardo ok va il suo vice un mio
addio ragazzi ci ho messo anni ba
[ __ ] dove si sa dove stiamo andando
e normale che va ok forse non è normale
che scenda così un ascensore per te ok
allora se avevamo la possibilità di
uscire prima
adesso mi sa che non ce l'abbiamo più
devo che cazzo devo fare usali qua sopra
sono uscito dall'ascensore ma non è
normale che io riesco a volare a ma
eravamo sott'acqua no non lo so mi ami e
mi ero perso sta cosa dell'acqua
sinceramente non avevo capito va bene
così
usciamo dal suo posto di merda per
favore ok io devo soltanto arrivare alla
macchina ragazza
ok so che sapete che cosa sto per fare
ho bisogno di incitamento per dora
l'esploratrice [ __ ] che porta
ragazzi siamo abbiamo nel culo perfetto
è diventato tutto nero siamo siamo in
paradiso
vedo la luce san gennaro vedono luce ok
perfetto non è san gennaro siamo siamo
in un letto di ospedale
parla ragazzi questo è stato il finale
più profondo che io abbia mai visto in
un videogame complimenti fantastico
sappiate che io non lo so io gli darei
un nobel per la trama ma voi ragazzi se
vi do è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video trovato
nella vestizione sensi le prescritte
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video per ragazzi